die dunkle energie oder die kraft die
hinter ihr steht wird nach heutigen
prognosen irgendwann einmal dafür sorgen
dass das weltall auseinander fliegt das
todesurteil für sämtliches leben ein us
astrophysiker hat jetzt
lösungsvorschläge gemacht wie wir die
expansion des universums überstehen
könnten er denkt beispielsweise an
gigantische spiegel im hals mit denen
sich sterne bewegen lassen ein super
spannendes gedankenexperiment jetzt die
klicks um science-fiction hier gibt es
täglich faszinierende wissenschafts
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
die dunkle energie ein noch immer super
mysteriöses thema in der physik und
kosmologie und es ist ja immer noch
nicht sicher ob es sie so gibt oder sie
eine folge der stringtheorie ist
forschungsteams weltweit verstehen
dieses phänomen noch nicht wirklich doch
die dunkle energie agiert wohl wie eine
art anti schwerkraft die das universum
auseinandertreibt zudem wird sie wohl
umso größer je mehr sich der raum
ausdehnt eventuell wird diese mysteriöse
dunkle energie in zukunft sogar
übermächtig dann würde sie nicht nur
sterne und galaxien auseinander reißen
sondern auch atome und moleküle und zwar
so lange bis nur noch strahlung und und
zerlegbare teilchen existieren
schätzungen zufolge könnte es in zehn
milliarden jahren so weit sein dann hat
sich das weltall vermutlich so weit
ausgedehnt dass am firmament nur noch
einige wenige dutzend nachbargalaxien
der milchstraße zu sehen sind das licht
der anderen sterne kann uns dann nicht
mehr erreichen da der kosmos immer
stärker auseinander gedrückt wird
doch bis dahin wird sich die
zivilisation vielleicht noch einmal
extrem weiterentwickelt haben und jede
menge fremder galaxien besiedeln doch
die dunkle energie würde dann die
abstände im all gestreckt haben und eine
kommunikation zu anderen galaxien wäre
unmöglich so halt stopp als jetzt
irgendjemand denkt dass sich fieber habe
und herumspielen ein
genau auf diesem worst-case-szenario
denken manche teams aus astrophysikern
und physikern herum und das obwohl es
für viele bestimmt nach science-fiction
pur klingt das alles ist natürlich ein
reines gedankenexperiment aber super
spannend konkret geht es um einen online
aufsatz des us astrophysiker denn huber
der university of chicago vom juni 2018
er schlägt riesige konstrukte vor die
innen mit solarzellen gepflastert sind
diese hohlkugeln müssten die
hochentwickelten bedrohten lebewesen der
zukunft dann um ihre jeweiligen sterne
bauen diese hypothetische konstrukt ist
nicht neu sondern wird in der
fachsprache als dyson sphäre bezeichnen
wir hatten ja hier darüber berichtet im
idealfall umschließt solch eine kugel
einen stern komplett und kann so seine
ganze energie absorbieren oder umlenken
und damit optimal nutzen beispielsweise
um ihre planetensysteme zu beschleunigen
wie denn huber in seinem aufsatz
schreibt das wäre wichtig um der
ausdehnung des alls zu entgehen und eben
in die andere richtung zu fliegen
der astrophysiker geht noch weiter und
führt auch aus wie genau zukünftige
zivilisationen ihre sterne bewegen
könnten nämlich mit einem konzept das
schon seit einigen jahrzehnten existiert
und von dem ingenieur leonid stoff
stammt ein gigantischer spiegelt auf der
einen seite des sterns würde das
sonnenlicht reflektieren die bewegung
des sternes resultiere dann daraus dass
auf der einen seite des sterns licht
entkommt und auf der anderen seite eben
nicht so könnte ein stein etwa 0,01
prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit
erreichen doch auch huber selbst erkennt
dass das bestimmt nicht reicht um der
dunklen energie zu entkommen und steckt
weitere ideen für zukünftige
zivilisation vor beispielsweise könnten
diese sterne bewegen indem sie die
schwerkraft anderer himmelskörper
ausnutzen so der wissenschaftler
insgesamt fünf sterne hat der us
physiker identifiziert die man mit
dieser technik wohl bewegen könnte sie
alle sind vom format unserer sonne
beziehungsweise etwas leichter denn
genau solche exemplare liefert seiner
ansicht nach noch genügend energie und
brauchen zudem ihren brennstoff auf
langen reisen nicht so schnell auf und
schlussendlich selbst super noch einen
drauf seiner meinung nach sollten wir
gezielt nach zivilisationen suchen die
diese taktik bereits anwenden doch wie
soll man diese aufspüren
ein hinweis sein außergewöhnlich schwere
oder extrem leichte sterne in den von
ihnen besiedelten galaxien denn alle
anderen seien ja von dyson sphären
ummantelt war aber wie kommen wir jetzt
dahin denn eins wird immer klarer der
aufenthalt im weltall ist für
astronauten und astronauten
lebensgefährlich unsere video premiere
auf dem englisch
kanal hier draufklicken webspace life
threatening forrester aus also sehr
spannendes video
ich freue mich auf euch auf dem
englischen kanal stay tuned csu